determine is officially over
I just finished my round nine game and
it was
probably the craziest game of the
tournament for me also one of the
craziest games I've ever played and part
of it was due to botched preparation and
some hallucinations and then a flurry of
sacrifices and a crazy crazy finish
so I'm still trying to process it I just
finished
maybe 15-20 minutes ago
and I was playing a young kid whose
feeder rating is I believe around 2100
he was having a pretty good tournament
and I had only about half hour to
prepare for him before the game I saw
that he plays Sicilian so I decided to
play E4 this is my second time playing
E4 as white this tournament I played E4
in the first round so we've come full
circle but after he plays C5 and the
first round I played Knight C3 in this
game I chose Knight F3 because I saw
that almost every game he had in the
database he's played E6 and I decided to
go for a pat line of mine that I studied
maybe back in 2015 2016. it's a move
Pawn to C4
and at first it looks a little bit
anti-positional I'm giving or
potentially giving away the D4 square
but uh it's a very tricky sideline and
in many cases white will end up playing
D4 and go into kind of an open Sicilian
Marathi behind position uh but that did
not happen so in just a moment I'll show
what did happen
there's like a drop of coconut water
left what to do
uh I still have uh normal water so keep
this by my side so
um he played Knight C6 I played Bishop
E2 and there's some nuances here the
more common move is Knight C3 but this
allows Knight D4 which uh is actually an
annoying line so Bishop to E2 uh
basically avoids Knight D4 because then
I can take and after Pawn takes the
knight's not hit
um but after bisbee2 there's a bunch of
interesting options for black for one
there's a pawn G5 which I did prepare a
little bit before the game uh there's
also Pawn E5 which maybe looks weird at
first because it loses a Tempo having
played E6 and 95 but uh it actually
makes sense to just clamp down on D4 and
it leads to a very closed position so I
Was preparing
um E5 and G5 before the game but then he
played Knight to F6 which for some
reason confused me because I thought I'd
checked this position before the game
and I had vaguely remembered that the
engine gave E5 with a big plus for white
and I was trying to figure out how white
can be better after this move
so I took a bit of time here but
ultimately I just decided to play E5
because I thought I knew the engine
evaluation like a given maybe plus one
or plus 1.5 but I just checked my prep
and I realized that I checked Knight F6
in this position and then this is where
E5 is given actually the edge is not
huge for white it's only like plus 0.3
plus 0.5 so I completely misremembered
what I looked at before the game so we
got to this position and I thought I'm
better because I thought I knew the
engine evaluation but uh E5 is actually
just a really bad move
because Knight G4 and my epon's
overextended
but during the game I didn't know I was
worse I thought like momentum is on my
side I thought I'd caught him in some
opening uh opening prep but uh let me
just show like what I should have done
is Knight C3 like play normally and then
uh prepare D4 in uh in the coming
position
and what if what if Queen C7 here
oh yeah Queen C7 D4 yeah this was uh
this is kind of what I was looking at
before the game
um as well but anyway I played E5 he
played Knight G4 I didn't know like
White's already objectively worse but I
came up with idea Pawn B4 which is a
really interesting type of Gambit that
there's only been one game on leechas no
games on the Masters database so it's
almost a novelty but I came up with this
because I remembered uh an opening it's
actually the opening named after Anna
crowling's dad let me show it in 1969 my
dad for the very first time played the
Beyond Gambit which was an opening that
he invented every Frozen says that it's
a very interesting opening so if you
don't trust me then trust Derek Rosen
it's a Gambit against English
C4 E5 Knight C3 Knight F6 Knight F3 E4
Knight G5 B5 this is uh what is it
called
the yeah the bell and gambits Beyond
baby Bayonne Anna's dad is uh from Spain
to be five now this is
yeah the first game in the first game is
in 1969. so B5 it's a cool move the idea
is after takes black can play D5 and get
the center uh and then there's another
Gambit that's been trendy recently C6
idea after takes takes takes there is
this line D5 takes takes Knight G3 H5
so the reason why I'm showing both of
these gambits is because what happened
in my game ended up being a combination
of a lot of ideas that you see in these
lines of course it would be reversed
because Black's the one gameting but
let's go back to the game and we'll see
uh some parallel ideas uh now of course
if he takes I'm happy to get the center
with D4 and light should have full
compensation here but he played the most
critical line is to take on E5
and after takes takes takes I basically
saw all of this when I had played
actually when I played E5 I was
calculating this line and the point is
after Bishop takes E5 I have D4 now I'm
not winning a piece unfortunately
because there's Bishop B4 check uh which
is maybe the only move
although I have the engine turned on
engines giving Bishop D6 as an
alternative which I was aware of during
the game the idea is after takes takes
my Rook is trapped and uh black is is
winning here so
there are a couple ways for black to not
lose a piece but he played Bishop B4 I
played King F1 and then he played Knight
to G6
and here I was remembering the scambit
against English this one I just showed
where the nighttime G3 and black plays
this early H Pawn thrust and basically
employing the same idea here with Pawn
H4 I just want to play Pawn H5 kick the
Knight and eventually Pawn H6 and yeah
during the game I thought uh I have full
compensation for being down upon the
engine says it's minus 1.5 in Black's
favor so I really miss evaluated but uh
I I was feeling good and I think that
that actually allowed me to play better
chess a bit later
so he played H6 which is a typical way
to prevent me from eventually playing H6
and it actually reminded me of my
previous game in round eight where I was
black I was pushing my H Pawn and my
opponent played the move H3 to prevent
the same idea of getting the pawn too
far
so here I decided to hold off on Pawn H5
and I started with Queen to B3
he played Bishop to D6 and it is a
little bit awkward for black because if
he plays Bishop E7 I would play H5 and
the Knight is not finding a great square
like either Knight f8 or Knight H4 but
both squares are very awkward so he
played Bishop D6 to keep the Square open
for the night
and I developed Knight C3 he castled and
now I play H5 taking the knights back to
E7
and here I was trying to figure out how
to just maximize my temporary lead and
development and also try and formulate
an attack on the king side I was
considering moves like C5 and 94 or both
of these moves like back to back but
ultimately I decided on the Move Pawn to
G4 and the reason is because Black's
committed to H6 the prospect of G5 would
guarantee the G file to open and I
thought if I can play G5 and Rook G1
there is going to be a massive attack
and maybe later Knight E4 and swing the
queen over and get all the pieces
involved so yeah I had some some devious
plans in mind he played the move Bishop
to ba here which
looks like he's setting up for Fisher
random chess uh just putting the bishop
on the back rink now the only developed
piece for lack is a knight on E7 but the
point is he's getting out of the way of
the d-pawn and he's preparing Pawn D5 to
contest the center
so I was considering playing G5 here but
I chose not to because I wasn't sure
about the line after it takes
and why did I not play G5
I forget why I didn't play G5
I was strongly considering it but I I
chose a different move instead which
looked a little bit more attractive was
Pawn to D5
and the point of this I'm just trying to
clamp down on the center and prevent
black from pushing the d-pawn two
squares and I was trying to make it so
if black wants to develop this bishop
with moving the d-pawn the only move to
do so would be D6 which kills other
Bishop yeah we're gonna see that both
Bishops have a hard time finding life in
the position so here he played Pawn to
E5 which maybe aims to keep the center
closed and also prepare Pawn D6 to give
life to a light squared Bishop
and now I go for G5
he pretty quickly took the pawn which I
wasn't entirely expecting and initially
when I played G5 I thought I would just
take back with the bishop and prepare H6
but then I realized it's not so simple
if I take with the bishop he has a move
F6
and black actually gets some initiative
I'd have to retreat somehow like Bishop
E3 and then D6 it actually seems like
black is doing okay here like if I ever
play H6 and there's G6 or G5
so I took some time before deciding if I
want to recapture and the move I ended
up playing I was actually very happy
with because rather than recapturing on
G5 I sacrificed another Pawn I play the
move Pawn to D6
and this is the third Pawn I'm
sacrificing now he didn't take the pawn
but if he does Bishop takes D6 I would
have either 94 or Bishop takes G5 I
wasn't sure whether I was going to play
in the game let's say Bishop takes G5
but now the point is if at six I have
the in between move C5 unleashing the
diagonal and this was a reason to give
away or one of the reasons to give away
the d-pawn is to eventually open up this
diagonal have the x-ray vision against
the king
now the other reason to give away the
d-pawn was to completely destroy the
life of the lights great Bishop which is
just having a very hard time finding a
path into the game
so he didn't take on D6 which surprised
me a little bit he played the move
Knight C6
and this allowed me time to play C5 and
now I'm holding on to my D6 pawn and
these two pawns essentially kill both
Bishops
like it's so hard for black to activate
the Bishops Meanwhile my Bishops have
life in the position I was feeling very
very good here there's ideas 94 and H6
and we'll see how the position flows for
white uh after he plays King h8 I start
with 94 hitting the pawn he defends with
F6
and then I play H6 my dream is to open
the H file
of course as black he uh he wants to
keep the H file closed so he plays G6
and around here actually like when I
played H6 I had already seen a really
cool mating idea that involves
sacrificing the queen we're gonna see
how how things play out but uh the point
is to get the pawn to H7 and it seems
like the Pawn's not going anywhere
because the king's in the way and how do
I actually get to the king I want to
open up the diagonal but the structure
is very solid so very soon we're gonna
see the idea that allows white to break
through he played the move on B6
I play Queen D5
and this move maybe seems random it
seems like maybe I'm trying to pressure
the queen side but I'm setting up the
idea is after he plays Bishop B7 and I'm
pretty sure he didn't see my next move
coming I play the move Bishop to C4
and it's already
Unstoppable checkmates the threats in
the position is Queen to G8 sacrifice
the queen and then
take and promote to a new Queen with
double check
and mate and I was a little bit
disappointed that my opponent did not
allow the the queen sacrifice for mates
but he did allow I guess a different
Queen sacrifice he played the move King
G7 here
and then I
promoted is this a pawn sacrifice or a
queen sacrifice
because I I end up losing a pawn but I
also lose a queen but yeah in the end it
is Checkmate on F7
now after the game a good friend of mine
uh Costa kubitzki messaged me and he was
upset that I didn't promote to a bishop
uh which didn't even cross my mind
um but I already had two Bishops on the
board so I would have had to like pause
the clock and ask the tournament
director for a third Bishop which Maybe
wouldn't be the best sportsmanship but
what did cross my mind during the game
is if let's say my opponent plays 97
hitting my queen twice I was thinking
that would be funny to play Queen G8
and whatever it takes on G8
I would take back
and under promote to Rook but then I
realized
I would have to again like pause the
clock and ask for a third rook and I
didn't want to make a scene and I also
didn't want to be on sportsmanlike but
it would be funny to finish this game
with three Rooks on the board and it's
super rare that you see a double
checkmate with both Rooks attacking the
king uh what you call this perpendicular
so yeah that's my tournament I finished
with five and a half out of nine I'm
super grateful for everyone tuning into
the Recaps it was super tiring I had so
many games that lasted over four hours
and uh I've not been getting so much
sleep it's been it's been weird sleeping
and eating schedule but I've really had
fun
um especially with this last game
so do stay tuned for maybe different
type of content in the coming days the
Vegas chess Festival begins I'm not sure
when the recap will go up but if you're
in Vegas feel free to say hi to me I'll
be here through June 18th or 19th I have
to check my itinerary but again thanks
so much for for watching I appreciate
those who watch the full video through
and now I think it's time to shave my
beard
um I do appreciate everyone in the
YouTube comments complimenting my beard
and
saying to keep it and grow it it does
give me more self-confidence
but um what's that famous quote
what grows on your face in Vegas
stays in Vegas